est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas quand même
en train d'un principe d'urgence qu'on
aurait dû respecter qui aurait dû
prévaloir dans cette affaire un principe
d'urgence c'est-à-dire d'accueillir oui
je crois que c'est irresponsable que de
présenter les choses ainsi
le principe qui devrait être le nôtre en
tous les cas guider les pays c'est le
choix que font les pays en matière de
politique migratoire dans l'intérêt de
leur population
qu'il y ait des gens moi j'ai de la
compassion pour ces gens là je veux dire
je souhaite que on les sauve quand il ne
périsse pas en mer etc
mais qu'ont les raccompagne de là d'où
ils viennent car nous n'avons rien à
leur offrir
et c'est ça la logique qui devrait
présider au choix des étapes c'est s'il
valait 6 des états veut l'accueillir
qu'ils accueillent mais si les états ne
veulent pas qu'on ne les oblige pas à
tenir face à cette situation si vous
aviez été par exemple chef de l'état
qu'auriez vous fait re et nous aurions
demandé que des bateaux repartent d'où
ils viennent nous aurions entamé
probablement depuis bien longtemps
des négociations avec d'autres pays
pourquoi la tunisie n'est-elle pas en
capacité alors qu'elle est toute proche
d'accueillir ce bateau nous aurait menés
au également probablement une autre
politique diplomatique qui vise à ne pas
déstabiliser les pays d'origine nous
aurions proposé nous nous avons proposé
nos oreilles ont installé la capacité
est ce que les demandes d'asile se fasse
dans les pays d'origine de façon à ce
que on ne met pas les pays devant le
fait accompli une demande d'asile se
fait dans le pays d'origine
elle est traitée par nos services
consulaires et ensuite si l'asile est
possible les gens peuvent venir s'il
n'est pas possible ce qui est le cas
bien souvent en tous les cas de ces gens
là en particulier et bien le traitement
se fait sur le territoire concerné mais
il n'y a pas de possibilité de mettre
les états devant le fait accompli parce
que c'est une histoire sans fin sur le
ce nouveau gouvernement italien dont on
a beaucoup parlé cette semaine c'est un
modèle à suivre pour vous pour le
rassemblement national
dans tous les cas ils tiennent leurs
promesses ils tiennent leurs engagements
et ils font ce pourquoi ils ont été élus
les italiens ont envoyé je crois un
signal très clair à l'union européenne
en leur disant nous ne pouvons plus
accueillir
nous ne pouvons plus nous ne voulons
plus accueillir tous ces migrants qui
viennent 700 mille migrants sont arrivés
sur les côtes italiennes durant toutes
ces années
eh bien ils ont des dirigeants qui leur
disent qu'ils ont entendu ce message qui
leur disent nous n'accueillerons plus de
façon indéfectible
tous ces gens